[Music]
I'm told you're a big fan of the
Bachelorette the share the Bachelorette
I do but you were not a fan of the show
The Bachelor
what now tell us what why you like one
so much and despise the other
all right I I don't despite I enjoyed
the bachelor every now and then but I'm
not I don't watch it I'm reading it I
miss why is it you just like The
Bachelor right well let's just set the
record straight okay right if you
wouldn't I'm pologize the Bachelorette
to me is really great because the show
is designed the Bachelorette is a
spinoff so the show is designed for a
group of women competing for a man and
so they decided to reverse the process
obviously for the spinoff so to see a
group of men competing for a woman and a
show that was designed for the opposite
gender immediately emasculates all the
men and the dudes they pick are all like
like big alpha male like they're they're
all they're usually kind kind of dumb
and they can't handle being in this
subservient position and having to
pretend like they're in luck it and they
go crazy right yeah you can't handle it
I love it's terrific
I don't watch okay you know what yeah my
assistant watches all those shows and
often at work when I've got to be
something else
sure sona is always I come out and she's
always watching The Bachelorette or The
Bachelor and saying I can't believe
Donny did that to Kimmy don't you know I
just making names up I don't know if
happening it's garbage you just said it
was great yes now if if you were not
married right do you think that you
would do well on The Bachelorette if you
were a contestant oh no yeah
sure you think you'd be you do very well
you probably win oh I was for sure when
no I would feel terrible that all of the
guys are waxed and super ripped and and
and they they're super tan so I would do
horribly yeah this because you have to
be in a hot tub and shows like that I
mean there are the women and that's
where I always look at those guys and I
always think I'm not gonna I look like
you know someone who's dying of
something in the late 19th century you
know and I'm in a hot tub they think
they think we have consumption yes
consumption sees that no one dies up
anymore
in the modern world up to us yeah it's
like and it's like it's Rick Kevin Steve
John and a consumption brothers oh yeah
oh sure I'm a late comer to Shark Tank I
got into it just this past like
Christmas break and I watched no joke in
the two week break I watched four
seasons of shark tank Wow
and I couldn't get enough of it and just
started buying all kinds of stupid stuff
oh you apply the product yeah all the
lot of the invention like the thing that
you put in your car so french fries
don't fall between your seat and why
does a real thing it's a real thing and
it will change your life and someone
made a you know billions of dollars what
if you count on those french fries for
later meals yeah then it's not for you
alright
salient point yeah thank you
you